well our defense and security Alice
Professor Michael Clarke joins me now
and Michael good to see you um let's
talk about what's happening on the
ground and we're going to focus first on
back but Russia appears to be making
gains around this city can you tell us
what we know yes it's the one place
we're on the ground the Russians do seem
to be making games the Wagner group are
attacking black motives they've made it
into their objective and they've tried
from the frontal assault from the East
they've tried from the north and that
was pretty disastrous but they do now
seem to be moving in from the south uh
they seem to have crossed the bakmutak
river and they're on the other side of
the river
um and there's some a lot of fighting
going on at kurdio mifka and andrifka
but even there even so they're about
eight or nine kilometers away from the
outskirts of back mode and that's all
open ground so if they are going to
attack from the south and I'm sure
that's what they will try to do they've
still got quite a lot of hard fighting
ahead of them but it does seem to be the
case that they are they're having a bit
more successive back mob but it is
costing them dearly to do so is that an
isolated area of gains then because of
course a lot is concentrated around
Hearst on the battle for that how's
Russia faring there everywhere else to
digging in and this is a really
interesting map this is done by The
Institute for the study of War who are
excellent and this is a really good
piece of research using a lot of
satellite data they have they've logged
where the Russians are digging in on the
east side of the Nipper River and so the
uh Kirsten Kirsten city is here the
ukrainians took Kirsten City and all of
these triangles represent fixed
fortifications which the Russians have
built all the Seas represent
concentrations of troops and a bit and a
Barracks there for instance another
Barracks here and what it shows us is
that the Russians are really fortifying
their side of the river opposite person
City but here this is Nova kakovka the
Russians really seem to expect the
ukrainians to try to cross the nippu
river probably around novakovka the
other thing that's interesting is that
you see how much have they fortified all
of their lines of communication they
obviously expect or worry that the
ukrainians will really try to invade as
it were the other part of the of the
oblast and so they they're protecting
their lines of communication they
obviously think I guess they've taken so
many troops away from curse and to send
them to donbass that their forces here
are relatively light so they've got to
have more fortifications it's a really
interesting map because it shows us what
the Russians are worried about
yeah very much so um
we had president zielinski saying look
you know cold dark days ahead and this
city has stopped when Moscow runs out of
missiles but you create a getting some
of their own yes the Americans are
talking about this ground launch small
diameter bomb and it's I mean uh Boeing
who work with Saab on this they say look
we've got plenty of rockets and we've
got some new accurate Warheads we put
the Rockets and the WarHeads together
very cheaply about 40 000 each which is
cheap for a missile and we can have lots
of them ready lots of them by Spring
next year it's very similar to The
Brimstone Brimstone 2 which we have
given the British you've given to uh the
ukrainians it's the same sort of thing a
standard rocket with a different sort of
Warhead on the thing that's good about
this from a uh the ukrainian's point of
view that the rocket itself Sprouts
Wings once it's been fired it's got a
range of about 100 miles and it's very
accurate so we all expect there to be a
resumption of this war at a greater
intensity after Christmas or after the
the winter as and when that happens
Rockets with Accu Rockets with a 100
mile range will be really useful to the
Ukrainian so in a way the Allies are
trying to think about what will the
ukrainians need in the spring when this
war will start up again at greater
intensity okay Michael for the moment
thank you Professor Michael Clark there
with analysis